joining us he's the chairman of the
House Intelligence is with us
congressman good to see you again thanks
for being with us looks perfect your
take on the firing of the deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe and the statement
of the Attorney General well as you know
we've had the FBI under investigation by
our committee for a long time on FISA
abuse and other matters so it doesn't
surprise me that mr. McCabe went
however our investigation still is
ongoing Mr McCabe still owes us answers
no matter where he's working and
eventually he's going to have to come
forward and provide those answers yeah
well one of the things he's gonna have
to provide the answers but I really see
he even seemed to in his statement
implicate James Comey did you catch that
as well that he knew about the leaks and
the media yeah I mean that's why this is
this is becoming so difficult right
there are so many witnesses now who have
testimony all over the map which is why
I think you continue to see this call
for somehow DOJ and FBI are going to
have to have somebody who can actually
investigate them and put all of this out
there now because we're continuing to
have problems in Congress just getting
the information that we need the latest
the latest example of that Shawn was the
text messages messages that emerged on
Friday night we did not have those text
messages and we had asked for those text
messages back in October November and
December
so it's it's very difficult for Congress
to get to the bottom of this and we
every day we find out something new
however I think at this point there's so
many crimes that have to be investigated
they need to get somebody over there
who's gonna who's gonna run a thorough
investigation and maybe work with the IG
when that report comes out and do we
know when we're finally getting this IG
report I mean I keep hearing one one
former head of the FBI or top FBI
official said it is pure TNT yeah I
don't I have not seen it I am NOT and I
have not been briefed by mr. Horowitz
that is really under the jurisdiction of
the Judiciary Committee and the
Oversight Committee however they do have
a lot of the IG does have a lot of
information that my committee is very
interested in when it comes to what what
we continue to look at and
faiza abuse yeah you know James
Kallstrom has been a longtime friend of
this program and he actually made this
statement former assistant FBI director
high-ranking people throughout the
government had a plot to protect Hillary
Clinton from being indicted in your
opinion based on what we know and 18 USC
793 which says you cannot miss handle
classified information similarly you
cannot destroy it then of course you
have subpoenaed emails that are deleted
acid wash bleach pit busting up devices
with hammers do you have any doubt in
your mind that those are crimes well as
you as you know our committee continues
to look at conspiracy we're looking at
obstruction or looking at misleading
Congress and also there's the statute
and a Civil Rights Code that involves I
think abuse of power and using your your
position to to go after someone
personally actually Greg Jared I've seen
him on your show many times he's talked
about this this provision and so there's
many crimes that have to be looked at
you know but I keep reminding people
Congress cannot prosecute all we can do
is make a referral to the Justice
Department and then the challenge is is
who are we going to refer it to because
as you know we don't know who over at
the Justice Department is involved in
this who would have to be Riku no
recused themselves because of their
involvement of their knowledge of what
happened over the last few years you
know I mean now the public of in his
poll that I referred to in the last
segment about the deep state is very
telling I want to ask you about two
issues involving James Comey the
president pointed out a testimony that
the that James Comey was under oath to
Senator Graham have you ever been an
anonymous source or known someone else
to be an anonymous source he said never
know did he do we now know that's not
true with the leak that we know that he
was involved in well you you bring up a
very valid point so somebody is lying
right so we don't know we don't know who
but those stories don't jive now I'm
sure by you know this is all out there
now they're gonna try to start to
cover-up
their tracks but this is what this is
why we have to have them back in to
answer these questions you know we still
have a questionnaire that's out that
they have not responded to that's
unacceptable and we needed to know when
exactly did they learn that the dossier
was paid for by the Democratic Party and
the Hillary Clinton campaign we do have
evidence of what Hillary Clinton did as
it relates to the email server we do
have evidence that in fact an
exoneration was written before an
investigation we do have evidence that
Hillary fixed the primary and we do have
evidence that she paid for a phony
dossier funneling money through a law
firm and that that dossier that she paid
for was then used to get and obtain a
FISA warrant with Grant with great
omissions and lies - on four separate
occasions to FISA judge's am I wrong on
any of that no I think that's that's
exactly right and so what we're trying
to determine here is who was involved at
the FBI and the Department of Justice
that made these decisions to move
forward not only to make the decisions
on what to do with the Clinton campaign
but then that's what mr. Gowdy and mr.
Goodlatte are investigating and the IG
and mr. Horowitz but we're also trying
to look at well how do who made this
decision to open up this investigation
and why was it done because it doesn't
appear to me like they had any credible
evidence to open up a
counterintelligence investigation and
that's what we just can't have in this
country where you have political dirt
that's paid for by one one political
party and used against another
especially using our foreign
intelligence capabilities it's just it's
just not it just can't happen in this
country it can't it's illegal the
comments seem very arrogant from both
James Comey and
this weekend as it relates to the
president it seems personal
and it seems abusively biased what is
your reaction to their comments yeah I
saw those comments over the weekend and
I was I was really quite surprised
because and this is again not helping
where we have to go in this country
right the American people expect the
intelligence agencies not to be
political and what you're seeing is the
comments that are coming out from the
highest levels of the intelligence
agencies from the last administration
are quite alarming I mean this is just
that just it's just way out of character
I mean you don't see former CIA
directors making those types of comments
like mr. Brennan made over the weekend I
don't I don't know why he did it you
know maybe he should retract it but
we'll see all right well it seems what
James Kallstrom said that high-ranking
people throughout the government had
applied to protect Hillary from being
indicted and I would add undermining
Donald Trump mr. chairman thank you sir
for being with us we appreciate it
thanks Sean